hey friends so here's the deal it is
Christmas Eve in Washington DC it is
only six degrees out and I'm gonna go
flow because apparently I'm just that
nuts come walk with me Drex here from
drexfactor POI sharing with you the love
of poi spinning and flow Arts to benefit
your body and brain and today I'm going
on a very very foolish errand but I
promise there's a good reason why but
before we dive in let me give a quick
shout out to the Friends of the channel
big dark monk fire Mecca flow fests flow
toys juggling calling pyro Terra light
toys spin balls and Ultra POI for
helping to make the videos on this
channel possible you can learn more
about all these amazing businesses and
what they're doing to support flow
artists like yourself by checking out
the links that I've got down in the
description of this video and special
thanks to non-business friends of the
channel Johnny Howard Lane machinsky and
Becca becklinen thank you all so very
much for your support from my work and
my mission so unless I miss my guess
this is going to be the last video I
record in 2022 I already have my flow
video queued up for Wednesday and there
will be a live stream on Friday evening
but uh yeah this will be
last one of the year how about that so
if uh you are in a position like most of
the United States is uh this weekend you
are seeing some of the lowest
temperatures we've seen in a very very
very long time
uh there's this big blast of Arctic
weather that worked its way down into
the lower 48 states of the United States
and uh
Colorado where I grew up they're like
looking at negative temperatures uh in
Fahrenheit right now and a lot of people
are stranded at airports because just
like they can't get planes to fly in
this stuff and I am bundled up as best I
can while still allowing myself some
freedom of movement because I have been
stuck inside now for the better part of
two days and I'm going a little stir
crazy and more than anything else I need
some movement in my life and you know
honestly this gave me an opportunity to
do a little bit of reflection too 2022
has been kind of a big year I became the
number one POI Channel on YouTube which
is pretty special and something I've
been looking forward to for years
um and I'm going to tie it together with
why I'm going out to flow right now I
swear so y'all remember that very very
famous quote from John F Kennedy where
he announces the beginning of the Space
Race where they're going to put a man on
the moon and specifically why we choose
to go to the moon in this decade and do
and do things
at that line we do these things
specifically because they're hard that
always kind of inspired me there's a lot
of things I've done in my life
specifically because they're difficult
and it's not that like I'm a masochist
that I enjoy putting myself through
painful situations although I would be
real with you it is already quite
painfully cold out here and we'll see
how long I last
but because sometimes by doing the hard
thing we also are able to grow as people
sometimes doing the hard thing is what's
necessary to get through whatever blocks
we happen to have and be able to you
know experience a new form of life that
can be very very rewarding you know
starting this YouTube channel was
certainly quite difficult growing the
YouTube channel was incredibly difficult
but
you know as it comes down nearly a
decade and a half later
you know doing the thing that was hard
was absolutely the feature instead of
the bug in the process I learned so much
about myself and my potential to grow
and be able to do cool new things in the
process it's really been awesome to see
an experience and so as I look back on
I'm really proud of myself not just for
reaching that goal but for the many
videos that were really hard for me to
pull off that I'm really proud of in
retrospect now in a lot of cases those
are not necessarily the most popular
videos on my channel but they are the
ones that I look back on and say yeah
I'm glad I got to do that and honestly
being outside right now and going to
flow this is something that I know is
going to make my body happy I don't
anticipate that I'm going to be able to
do it for a terribly long time but at
the same time I can feel in my joints
and muscles that need to move and
express and have a release and as
difficult as it is to be out in this
weather you know I know it's waiting for
me on the other side of that is a
feeling of satisfaction that I did do
the hard thing in order to make my body
happy which that's going to make me feel
good and I don't know what that might be
for many of you out there whether you
know changing careers learning a new
skill or hey even learning POI might be
a thing that you know looks like it's
going to be hard and that your little
loath to take on for that reason and at
the same time you find that there's
something really magical waiting for you
on the other side of that
we do these things
because they are hard
and I think there's something very
special and lovely about that I did
think briefly about doing a video that
was going to be a recap of my year and
you know telling you some of the awesome
stuff that I really like this year but
in the end I think that
this is really where I want to leave
things for uh for for 2022.
just with a moment of having a good time
and hoping it inspires some of you out
there
to go out and try some difficult things
yourselves yeah
here's open cool well I'm now my
favorite flow spot so let me pull out my
POI and let's see how long I last in all
of this shall we
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you foreign
[Music]
as predicted I'm really happy that I got
out and spun and now it is time for me
to go back indoors and bake some cookies
because I definitely feel like I've
earned it thank you all so much for
watching if you got anything out of this
video please make sure to like comment
subscribe and share keep the
conversation going and help my channel
grow yeah
[Music]
foreign
thank you because this video would not
be possible without the kind support of
all of these nice people right here
these are my flow patrons over on
patreon and they along with the people
listed down in the description helps
make this video and all the videos on
this channel possible thank you one and
all for your very generous supports uh
if you are not currently a supporter and
you would like to become one you can do
that by heading on over to patreon.com
dressfactorpoi you can do that by
following the link down in the
description or the card that just popped
up if you are watching on YouTube there
you can get access to a whole host of
awesome rewards and even better you'll
be helping me out in my mission thank
you for watching friends if you'd like
to see more Vlogs that I've recorded on
a variety of different Topics in the
flow Arts you can do that by checking
out a playlist of videos a link to that
that I will leave down in the
description as well as up on screen if
you are watching on YouTube the YouTube
algorithm also thinks that you might
like this top video here based on your
past viewing habit so maybe give that a
shot too I have very very happy New Year
everybody I hope you all stay warm out
there and I will see you very soon
peace